-Now, Carrie, since your book
is all about getting
healthy and fit,
I thought it'd be fun
if we played a new fitness game.
It's time for "Tonight Show"
Fittest of the Fit Challenge.
-♪ You wanna get fit,
you wanna get fit ♪
♪ Fittest of the Fit ♪
-All right. Our first challenge
is called the hang ten.
We have to race along
this course matching our hands
and feet exactly
to the pictures on the floor.
The first one to finish
wins the round.
Okay? Do you understand?
-Yeah.
-All right.
You -- Are you ready?
Have you ever done anything like
this before in your lifetime?
-Never.
-Yeah, me neither.
Maybe, like, "Dance Dance
Revolution" meets Twister.
It's really fun.
-Ooh, you're one up on me.
-All right, but I don't think
I'm going to win.
But either way. Hey, confidence.
Confidence is key.
All right. Here we go.
All right. You ready?
Let's line up. [Blows]
All right. On your -- Wait.
I just want to see what --
On your mark, get set, go!
-Aah!
♪♪
-Oh, God!
Oh, God! This is so hard!
-Aah!
-Oh, my God! You're killing me!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God!
♪♪
[ Bell dings ]
-Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
God. That was so embarrassing!
Oh, my gosh.
-That was harder than
you would think it would be.
-It really is tough, man.
Can we see that again?
Why? In slow motion. Here we go.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh. It was that bad?
Oh, my gosh.
What are you doing?
-It's beautiful.
-Now it is time --
I'm like -- Wow. Just clueless.
I'm like, "Hand, foot, what?"
Now it's time
for our second challenge.
This is called the Bodzilla.
-Yeah!
-And this time, we're
going to be working together.
One of us will put on a
blindfold and attempt to walk
through this tiny city
without knocking over
or crushing
any of the buildings...
while the other
has to hold a plank
and guide them by shouting out
where they should step.
Who's doing the, uh --
Who's doing the planking?
Since you won the last round...
-I --
That doesn't help, does it?
-No, it doesn't. Yeah.
It means you will be walking
blindfolded through the city.
And I have to do
a plank push-up?
-Just hold a plank.
-Just walk really -- Just jump.
[ Laughter ]
Just take a real --
Just start running from there...
-You know, I'm 5'3",
and I have super --
I don't -- I'm not tall.
-You can do this.
-I don't know if I can --
-Oh, my gosh.
-Blindfolded. But sure.
-Aw, bud, you can do this.
All right. You go over there.
-Okay.
-And I'll go down here.
And then -- Here we go.
It's all about --
-Okay.
[ Drum roll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ready? On your mark, get set.
All right.
Left, left foot, left foot.
Go! Left foot.
All right, right foot.
Straight up in the air.
Right foot.
Straight up.
Yes, yes, yes, perfect! Wow!
Left foot. You're great.
All right. Now right foot.
Big, big, big, big -- Yes.
No, no. Yes.
No! Yes! Yes! Perfect!
All right. Left foot. Yes.
That's -- Stop right there!
Just stop!
Just chill out for two seconds.
All right.
Left foot up in the air.
Now over, forward, forward.
Oh, higher, higher, higher!
Forward. No, no, no!
No! Yeah, stop, stop!
Now right foot.
Real big -- Giant step!
Yes, and you're done!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo!
-That was teamwork, man.
That was great.
Now, can we see that again
in slow motion?
-Yes!
♪♪
Look at that!
-Ooh!
-Come on. Bodzilla.
That's what I'm talking about.
It's time for the final round.
This is worth 10,000 points.
-Whoa! I know.
They're worth points.
-Whoever takes this round wins.
And this is a good one here.
This is called
the Huff and Puff Face-Off.
-What do I win?
-We -- Uh -- Um --
-What's my motivation?
-Bragging rights.
-Okay. That's enough.
-You have to crouch down
into a bear crawl while trying
to blow these three ping-pong
balls past the center line.
Whoever has the most balls
in the other person's side
after 20 seconds wins the game.
Whew. I'm already out of breath.
I haven't even done anything,
and I'm breathing heavy.
What did I do?
Are you ready for this?
-Let's do it.
-You go over there.
And, hey, good luck. Hey.
-Good luck.
May the best --
May the best man win.
-Yeah, or woman.
-Or woman.
-All right. Here we go.
Drum roll, please.
[ Drum roll ]
On your mark, get set, go!
[ Both blowing ]
-[ Shouts indistinctly ]
♪♪
[ Blowing continues ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Bell dings ]
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I win!
-Carrie Underwood, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]